i mean i went through a period in life
where you know i was the
stereotypical weave that didn't go out
and i had zero social skills
and how i learned was i think everyone
goes through that stage especially if
you go through university where you kind
of want to
you kind of want to reinvent yourself
right you move into someone new and you
want to
be a new person so what i did was i
basically just had like a full year
where i just went out as much as
possible
and talked to as many people as possible
just like try to go out my comfort zone
and that was [ __ ] hell for me as like
this introvert
it's kind of like a trial by fire period
of my life that i would never want to do
300 smart home training social stretch
it basically was because i
i literally i literally just did not
know how to socialize i didn't know how
to read a room i didn't know what the
social network was that's like such a
common like cultural thing in japan that
we actually have like our own
like phrase for it which is university
debut yeah
yeah really it's like it's like a
cultural thing in japan where like
because there are so many like
anti-social kids
in middle school and high school and
that when they go into university
they're like oh [ __ ] i'm like one step
closer to
where i have to socialize in order to
[ __ ] live
in society so university is literally my
last chance before i'm
thrown into that world so i'm gonna like
make a 180 during university and just
[ __ ] do
anything and everything possible to just
completely change myself around
i think it is a really op mindset when
you when you you know because
you know i wasn't cool at all in school
i was i was like very much an
in-betweener you know i wasn't cool but
i wasn't like i wasn't like on the
bottom of the social ladder if you will
you weren't like bullied to [ __ ] right
i mean that's because i started fighting
back my way out of the box
you know i was just kind of like
whatever like no one really paid
attention to me never had any luck with
like
you know dating or anything yeah i was
never had any of that but then i thought
like
oh wait like no one knows who i am in
university
yeah so like i don't know no one knows
i'm a mid-tier social
i'm a i'm a cto on the social ladder
right
i can i can reinvent myself and i think
well i didn't you know i didn't reinvent
myself it's just like
you don't do the mistakes you don't fall
back on crutches that you had like like
don't like you said right you go out
more you don't
you know i could play video games which
i is what i probably would prefer doing
but
if people invite me out i'll say yes
because you want to be seen as fun and
then if you seem as fun and everything
goes easier and you learn more you get
more confident
if for me it was go out of your comfort
zone for me it was like the complete
opposite
i was like the really social in middle
school in high school and then when i
entered university because i started
doing youtube yeah right i like kind of
regressed you also lived at home right
yeah i lived at home i can imagine
that's like
way you must feel did you feel like
different from like the other people who
are living on campus
oh yeah a little bit i mean our campus
was weird
because i think the majority of people
in my class did live at home
oh wow yeah we only had maybe like a
handful of people who actually lived
on campus which uh which which
university did you go to again uh sydney
university okay so i guess it's because
it's a city university yeah i mean we
have
our own campus and like dormitories and
stuff like that that uni
students live in but i think the
majority of people because it's such a
an accessible university because it's
like smack bang in the middle of like
sydney like city so people can just like
get on trains and bustles and just go
home basically yeah because i i feel
like no one in my class
who lived locally to the area really
from there well that's because you went
to swansea right and yeah
what is there to do in swansea well it's
a good question
i'm still wondering that myself
i didn't live locally either i lived
like an hour and a half by bus
[ __ ] so i didn't live close at all i
could have like i was at a distance
where i could have easily lived on the
dorm but then
i heard from people who were living in
dorms in sydney university they were
like don't do it that's a good
experience though
you know being thrown into hell honestly
i i feel like i learned
more valuable social skills um and just
life skills going to university
than i did actual career skills that i
was
using that that i learned from my course
i don't think i realized it until i left
and then i actually started like
functioning
yeah on my own yeah i don't i don't know
what i would have done without that
period in my life jesus said like
it basically taught me how to survive in
the world
and how people really are and all the
expectations i had
growing up and like because as a kid
right
you kind of expect that as you grow up
and the more mature you get you assume
that everyone's just gonna
realize what they're doing get mature
and then you kind of realize
um going through university especially
especially that that was a [ __ ] lie
and then you go out of university you
start like the working world and you
realize oh everyone here is just like
growing up university students and
everyone
nobody actually knows what they're doing
and everyone is still
secretly as immature as like adults
aren't as adult
as i thought they were right yeah i
don't know i feel like i don't
it's either like people just have their
[ __ ] together or they don't like there's
no in between like i don't know i've
never met anyone
most adults that i've met are just like
kids in suits essentially
that's basically the best way i can
describe it